[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are indeed very careful boys today we
got gianni
what's up y'all i'm so happy to be here
i love it i love you guys are you are
you italian yeah i am that's great
what does that mean
we're gonna hear about that a lot i
guess i actually you know what's so
funny
my name is super italian but i'm always
just like everyone just thinks yeah
you're just a normal white guy i'm like
yeah like no no you know what i mean
like when i go no auditions are like
johnny pillow they expect like some like
spicy
and i'm like
what's up what the [ __ ] are you doing
you know what i mean they're like
i took it for two years in high school
and i only learned one word
it was a beachy cleta it's bicycle oh
wow
i mean that too but like that was just
more like growing up well i get it you
know i'm just like in rhode island there
was all the hot italian girls were in my
class so it's me and like 25 girls so
every time the teacher would call me i'd
be like
and then she picked johnny get out and
be like yeah i'm doing great i'll get
out of here
it's fun
it means [ __ ] yeah it is
f word in italian
yeah yeah yeah no i didn't do that yeah
i think the nuts would have been over
the top oh speaking of that speaking of
nuts man
you guys have been i should not have
brought this up
trying to segue right into the [ __ ]
story
caucus is cool
story and it's so good we're like stop
it right there okay i need it how did
you even how did it even come you
brought it up you're talking about your
dick though
i was like hey gianni how are you and
you were like that's a girl my perfect
dog
you couldn't wait to get it out bro well
i don't know what it is had clock
surgery when he was blood yeah so he got
[ __ ] surgery but you know he got [ __ ]
surgery too so you guys are like [ __ ]
bros pointing at him you did
[ __ ] boys man i just got circumcised at
12. that's hardly like cosmetic
don't say
i don't think it works
boy
we can't do maybe maybe four or five
years ago we can't do that again maybe
you guys know
i don't know if that's a good way so you
got circumcised at 12 yeah was that like
really late oh it sucked that's true he
said it was the worst experience of his
life it's the worst thing yeah for sure
and then like your dick would like get
hard again and then it would like
instantly just i would just have so much
blood loss every like the amount of
blood that goes through a boner also
like that's how much you sleep yeah
why'd you do it
yeah why'd you get a boner i don't know
i get a border
[ __ ]
human [ __ ] body
yeah no why'd you get circumcised at 12.
i don't know it's my parents i was
[ __ ] i'm 12.
i'm not making your medical decisions
[Laughter]
oh no it sucks to say but yeah did you
get in trouble for something they're
like you know what we still got one
thing
no i was like why didn't i ask them i'm
like hey mom dad why did i not get
circumcised when i was born they were
like
yeah they just were like it was like the
[ __ ] filipino shrug
yeah i was like why would you guys they
were like oh you want to get now it's
like again it's 12th birthday they're
like happy birthday
they wheel them into the yeah so mine's
like the opposite story of you where i
ended up with something that looked like
a [ __ ] stitched up sausage yeah but
it's but it's cool now everything's
chill i don't know i haven't really
compared it with another dude
everyone take it out let's go boy
all right perfect yeah so basically so
basically what happened was i've never
told this story i don't know why i told
you guys like four people know this in
my life comfortable yeah yeah i came in
yeah i came in there there was no white
people in here and i felt comfortable
i'm like
i can breathe
um
and then he showed up and i was like all
right [ __ ] no more [ __ ]
no so basically what happened was i'll
get nervous now steve's here
i uh when i was like four
uh i would get hard and my dick would
like banana up and i would legitimately
pee in my own eye like i have a specific
memory of being at my my grandmother's
house and i pee and i would like pee in
my own eye and that was it that's all i
remember so but you had to pee with them
with a bonus i don't have a before and
after my four-year-old dick before and
after picture i don't yeah so this
happened once or you're peeing in your
eyes all the time it was all the time
but i just remember like in my memory i
was like oh yes yeah yeah my memory got
rid of all but it's like we're gonna
keep that one
just for later can i ask what you're
about to be or you're like i gotta pee
i i truly don't know like i just have
that this three second spotty memory of
it and when you're just like this there
wasn't even like a uh push it down with
my i know i i really don't know you
didn't do the whole [ __ ] pants all
the way down to your ankles like that
[ __ ]
here's the thing i was four i wish i
could tell you okay logically logically
just do this but i was for sure i was
just you know whatever dumb foreign
here's the thing man if i could go back
i would change a lot of things but you
know what is that the first thing that
was the first yeah i'd be like i would
have i would have actually no because it
worked out it ended up working out so
basically what happened was i got um
surgery on it and
like at four at four
it was around four it was that bad that
your parents was like we need to get
surgery for him yeah wow yeah because
you shaped it huh yeah wait how old are
you uh 25 now did google back then would
you do dick doctor
i don't maybe i went to a pediatrician
i have to like
honestly oh i'm i'm flying to vegas
right after this i'm going to the
airport i'm going to call my mom on the
way i'm like i don't know can you tell
me about this give me some insight yeah
i haven't really never asked her the
behind the scenes yeah give me the bts i
gotta i gotta send some clips of [ __ ]
jk news so they can splice them in
through your first appointment with like
consultation and doctor and like it
wasn't like going in i don't know did
they do nip tuck or they did like i
truly don't know is your doctor like
look i see a lot of four-year-old
penises and this one's weird
this one's bad he's like he's like
here's the good news it's gonna look
great
what did he do to
like i don't know it put a stick on it
it was like what was going on it was it
was banana and now it's just like it's
legitimately like if i was building a
home i always say this if i was building
a home i could use my [ __ ] as a leveler
like that's how perfect and straight it
is now and i'm not going to brag about
it because here's the thing it was a
good glow up but
it's perfect it's the perfect [ __ ]
around
the perfect [ __ ] it's like
your cat your dick can't pass parallel
so if you get hard is this parallel yeah
it's just it's [ __ ] here there's a
problem with that man you can't pass
parallel you know how you do that thing
where you can like like like bounce it
it just goes like it's it's like it goes
there and it's like yeah it's like there
yeah it's like a broken windshield wiper
it's like it won't come all the way
the perfect [ __ ] indeed
do you remember the healing process as a
kid because that must have been
traumatic i don't i don't remember
peeing in your eyes i remember peeing in
my eye and then i just remember
having a perfect [ __ ]
so you blocked it all out yeah but i did
block it all out yeah have you ever been
with a girl that really realized it's
how straight it was yeah i like
the thing
it's now it sounds cocky but like every
time i hook up with a girl they're like
you have the most perfect dick and i'm
just like yeah i know
the answer is yes and it's not me it's
not even like me it's like it's not like
i did anything i'm just like yeah yeah
you didn't tell them the story first no
yeah yeah you didn't tell them they're
surprised that's a straight dick yeah
dude imagine loving your dick so much
that you're like it's not me it's god
look it's god doctor o'connor at uh
women in infant you know
very humbling i thought the perfect dick
for chicks would because you're trying
to hit the g spot right so it would be
like this yeah i do have to do some
double action sometimes because it
doesn't get yeah it depends on the angle
right but like uh you know when you get
like an uppercut do you think you get
like a nrv or something like that you
know what i'm talking about no reason
boner and it's like like does it lean on
one side of the pant it's just straight
man
so your picture just tucks back like the
biggest eye it's like a sundial
yeah does it hurt if you do the whole
tuck under the [ __ ] belt thing
um no it's just it's because it's
actually just straight so like if it if
it like people who have like uh like it
would probably be like that but it's
just like chilling up there like oh
straight up
fascinating
yeah
i'm pulling up here and i'm talking to
nick in the car real quick and joe's
like yo see we're gonna roll right now
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
in there
and then i come in here you gotta get
this conversation we gotta [ __ ] start
rolling dude
this story's gonna be [ __ ] hype and
and then and then it's like it's a dick
story i'm like okay that is good
[Laughter]
breaking news here on jk news
[Laughter]
it's good for you man thank you man
thank you seriously thank you
so you're wrong you're you're on power i
don't know i just i over share all the
time and i go i like leaving i'm like
[ __ ] i just talk about my [ __ ]
so next time i come on i'll tell you
guys about my [ __ ] story that
he's gotta have something to look
forward to if it's not perfect doctor's
like in order to get you the perfect
[ __ ] i gotta [ __ ] your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's like we have to put a thing in the
middle so you have to have two [ __ ]
now and i'm sitting there i'm like seems
reasonable i'm gonna put your old [ __ ]
in here
and here's what it used to look like
you should have seen your face when you
were four then i had to do the same
thing
so you you're on uh power yeah so i was
originally on power and then um that
show ended and then me and another
character got a spin-off and it's called
power book two it's literally just a
continuation of power totally thinking
about power 106 uh power what is power
how it's a show what's 50 cent show yeah
it's 50th century oh
yeah um and yeah so we just um
when is this coming out
okay so the season finale it would have
just aired the previous sunday and we're
filming season three now today's video
is brought to you by draftkings the
moment we've been waiting for since
september who's here
in honor of the big game draftking
sports book a official sports betting
partner of super bowl
56 is giving new customers 56 to 1 odds
on either team wow bet just five dollars
and get 280 in free bets if your team
wins draftkings sportsbook is now live
in new york which means you can bet from
almost one third of the country if
sportsbook isn't in your state yet play
the draftkings daily fantasy football
contest for super bowl 56. new customers
can get a free shot at the one million
dollar top prize with their first
deposit download the draftkings
sportsbook app use the promo code off
the record and get a 56 to one odds on
either team bet just five dollars and
get
280 in free bets if your team wins
that's promo code off the record at
draftking sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of super bowl 56 21 plus
minimum age and location requirements
vary by jurisdiction draftkings.com
sportsbook for full list of requirements
and state specific responsible gaming
resources void where prohibited gambling
problem call 1800 gambler in tennessee
call or sex the tn redline
1-800-889-9789
or visit ccpg.org chat in new york call
877
h-l-p-e-n-y or text h-o-p-e-n-y
4-6-7-3-6-9 download the draftkings
sportsbook app use promo code off the
record that just five bucks and get 280
and three bets if your team wins wow so
yeah right on me
thank you i appreciate it that's tight
so we're on season three right now yeah
we're we just started the first episode
of season three does 50 cent know about
your perfect car i have not told them
but i think why not i think it'll come
up after he watches jk news because i
know he's a big fan
do you call him 50 or do you call him
like curtis i i first i called him
curtis and then like once i got closer
to him everyone just calls him five they
call five oh they don't even oh you
could shorten it it's like if somebody
wanted to call me tony versus anthony
it's like five instead of 50. that's
pretty good yeah so just just going five
but at first it was like mr jackson and
then it was like curtis and then it was
50 and then it was fine you're about to
look them in the eyes you have to look
at the floor the whole time no he's
actually the sweetest dude ever like
yeah he'll he'll come in like at first i
was intimidated and then he's scaly
yeah he's he's [ __ ] shredded and then
he would come in and then he'll just sit
down with you and like talk like movies
and david fincher i'm like holy [ __ ]
yeah
oh
so funny
yeah he's like talking about
cinematography i'm like what the [ __ ]
wow that's it yeah who would have known
he's the only guy that's been shot nine
times that enjoy cinematography
yeah he's a big cinematographer i've
always wanted to know like is he is he
doing that he's like hey look i know i
have a bad day i got shot nine times
he's like listen i know they [ __ ] up
your breakfast at crafty butt
i almost died yeah
i'll show you the holes yeah that's
about times i got shot
time johnny picks up a banana he's like
hey did you know that uh
my dickie
[Laughter]
i don't know where to go okay man
it's perfect now that's all that matters
you know how did you get into acting and
all that stuff is that something you
always wanted to do yeah so when when i
was growing up i was probably like
10 11 um and i was playing hockey so i
actually was drafted to me
professionally for hockey yeah i had
like as an 11 year old no no not at that
point but like when i was 16 um and i uh
i was playing that's all i ever did but
i just remember just being an
entertainer and like i love just
performing and stuff like that but i
didn't ever know what it meant like i
was just in the locker room being funny
with the team so like the coaches would
come up to me like bro you like you
should do like
entertainment acting stuff and i always
thought they were just trying to
[ __ ] with you yeah so i like wouldn't be
in competition with their son
that was where my brain went so i was
like [ __ ] that i'm never going to do
that yeah
so then once i was like yeah
14 15 i started taking like theater
classes because you had to at school
i was such an [ __ ] in like high
school and just trying to make everyone
might be funny and then in theater class
the teacher was like yeah do it and i
was like wait i'm not getting kicked out
of class she's like no go you want
people go on the stage and she just let
me do whatever i want and it like
changed like my life and i was like oh
cool and then you leave the room and she
picks up the phone and she's like get my
son in the [ __ ] football team
the coach is like you're [ __ ] good
yeah i tried for years
he's too good at football he's good
football he's gonna acting
so yeah and yeah and then i moved to la
when i turned 19 i stopped playing
hockey and um yeah i just started
auditioning working shitty jobs the
usual and i [ __ ] grinded for years
and now
you're on a show that's crazy i mean i
met johnny because uh through theo and
like through uh all the you you worked
on his podcast yeah um and then
i thought that you were just a producer
for a lot of podcasts yeah because you
did so much of that stuff but i didn't
know that you were
started like booking voice over stuff
and booking you know guest stars in a
like different show so i was like oh i
have enough money now um so i don't have
to work a restaurant job i want to still
do something creative so i honest i met
someone on set uh because we shot that
movie in mississippi and i was listening
to this past weekend and at the time it
was theo's podcast and it only had like
50 000 viewers so if you listen to theo
you're like oh [ __ ] like you know com
you know what i mean so someone knocked
on my trailers one of the pas he's like
you know let's go to set and he was like
were you listening to theo i was like
yeah he's like dude he grew up on my
dad's farm no and i was like oh [ __ ] so
he's like yeah i'll link you up with him
when i um when you get back to la so i
was like dope so like a month later i
filmed the movie i had money i was like
okay cool like i can be comfortable but
i was just auditioning i was like i
still want to do something every day
where i wake up and go do something so i
reached out to theo i was like i just
want to help you with your podcast and
do your social media and do stuff like
that and i looked like every guest was
on that show for like three
years-ish i booked we moved into a new
studio um you know we ran socials we did
all that stuff and i just got i just
knew how to do it and we got good at it
and he [ __ ] blew up obviously
everyone knows theo now he's like when i
started working with him he had like i
think he had like forty two thousand
followers and you blew him up yeah i was
like yeah i was like you know [ __ ] we
got the guy behind to get the brace
behind the operation right now you know
how's everything if you if you guys need
some help i'll let you know after the
potty oh we need some help bro we need
some help
i just i just say that because i
like it's so crazy to see someone like
42 000 and then 2.5 million in a year
just to see what like he did it was so
incredible and insane and i mean he's
the funniest person he's hilarious the
funniest and i know him like on such a
personal level where it's like sometimes
when you know someone like that they're
not funny to you anymore she's even
funnier like it's just crazy like the
stuff that he says like even in deep
deep deep conversations like he'll say
something i go i don't know how the [ __ ]
you just came up with that it's just
funny so then i started working with uh
you know santino because they knew who i
was and i helped him with this you know
i built out his tick tock and now um
uh
i helped brendan brennan shop a little
bit my little brother's over there
fighting the kid and now my thing that i
still do i still do social media for
comedians and i don't get paid i
literally just do it because i love
doing it um i just got chris stefano to
a million followers on tick tock he's
never logged in and i just like post
stuff and
yeah so i just do it because i like it's
literally fun you're sitting on set for
like four [ __ ] hours not doing [ __ ]
and i'm like i just find comedy clips
and i post them and that's tight man i
just i just like think like people the
guys who i know are great comics and
like deserve it i'm like these guys
deserve it they just need guidance yeah
and i just know how to clearly like it
too you like comedy of course yeah yeah
i love you surround yourself with that
much comment you didn't like it yeah
have you ever thought about um just
trying that out for yourself like doing
stand-up stand up for like a year and a
half i did open mics and i didn't
i actually got booked on a ton of shows
but i didn't love the um
the you do the same material for like
two years that was one thing that i just
personally was like
i'm like if i tell this [ __ ] story two
more times it's already gonna feel old
to me and that was the first time i ever
told it you know what i mean so it's
like i i i respect the craft at what
they do of like perfecting a joke and
like even one word change could change
the whole flow of the joke i respect it
and i love it but for me personally it
just felt like i was hearing myself talk
well again threw it away every year i
mean there's there's a couple guys who
do that i mean that's easy but yeah yeah
it's like writing a feature film and
then like work working it live yeah you
know and then trying to fix it and all
that that's the crazy part yeah and i'm
the type of person i like i like new
experiences and new things and you know
new information and a lot of that is
just yeah you're doing like i've seen
theo
over maybe 300 times live
and he's every joke still makes me laugh
every time theo is actually extremely
funny in real life more like it was so
surprising um we were booked
like
like simultaneously just coincidentally
in minneapolis i was in the audience and
he popped up and i was like what the
[ __ ] feels here really and then i i
[ __ ] cried laughing i haven't done
that in ages dude i was like this guy
his life is way better than his podcast
yeah his podcasts are still good too but
i was super surprised yeah that's what
everybody says when they go same live
they just said like it's the hardest
i've laughed in like years yeah that's
what i heard i don't even know what he's
saying it's just funniest
yeah i haven't met him yet because all
you [ __ ] do without me
yeah he'll just end a joke like that's
what happens when you put a cigarette
and a waffle and you're like what the
[ __ ]
but yeah so yeah i've seen him live a
ton of times and every time he makes me
laugh and i really you know it's the
same joke you're like the same joke
i know it's coming i know i know his i
could tell you his hour right now i
could do it if you guys want me to i can
i could just do the whole hour right now
let's do it yeah if you have a favorite
joke of this where you start to hear the
warm-up for it and you're like oh yeah i
love this one he has one random joke
where it's every time it makes me laugh
so [ __ ] hard he just he'll he'll go
to the like at the comedy store he does
it and stuff like that he'll just like
get up on stage and at the beginning
when no one knew who he was it was
so much funnier because he people like
who the [ __ ] is this guy he would get on
stage and it's already in his special so
i'm not burning any bits but he was like
um you know uh my cousin got bit by a
gay guy the other day and then he'll
literally wait like 10 seconds of just
like nodding his head and he'll just go
so we'll see
[Laughter]
and then he'll just go right like into
the next joke
i i was like it's just so next level of
just like he doesn't give a [ __ ] it's so
funny and i'm like
every time ten words dude yeah every
time i hear that joke i'm like that is
the perfect joke like yeah so is that
how you got on
is that how you got on tv is like you
were doing podcast producing and while
doing auditions i had booked all that
but so i had done um a guest stop i've
done four guest stars on different shows
a couple abc family shows uh a couple of
you know fox comedies like stuff like
that um and then i shot that movie ma
and then after all that i i went and
started helping out with the comedy so i
would already booked a ton of stuff and
then
um i i wouldn't have i would not have
liked it if it was the other way like i
was doing podcasting like oh now i'm an
actor like i wanted to like get my life
together and like that and then i was
like okay now i want to kind of get into
this so that's where you were like yeah
that's that's when you mentioned i had
the money in the free time yeah so
that's when you're able to just be like
oh i don't need to hustle like that
exactly oh i was actually hustling
harder at that time because i was like
doing the podcast stuff and i was then i
had to go to an audition and then i you
know what i mean i would then i would
fly and go you know shoot an episode of
something and then i would literally be
like on the flight like booking a
[ __ ] guess like sebastian's coming in
and sebastian's manager is calling me
and i'm on set of like power like
shooting an episode i'm like yeah
sebastian here like you know what i mean
and i'm just like on set and it was so
funny because nobody knew i was just
like an anonymous email on on the thing
and nobody knew and then uh like then
they started coming the podcast and
people would recognize me go oh like
you're on that and i'm like yeah so then
it started coming as like oh they knew
that i was an actor as well yeah and
then you come train with us and get
punched by nick yeah i did beat the [ __ ]
out of nick that day but um he beat the
[ __ ] at me yeah this guy's very good but
then i i met nick through um cause i did
tiger belly and then i met gil and then
gil's like come train and then yeah
that's kind of got hooked up with with
you guys small world man nick will teach
you how to take a punch and [ __ ] go
down get knocked out bro yeah
all right dude how much time we got left
let's [ __ ] get it
i'm flying to vegas in [ __ ] four
hours so let's get it
you